in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Sam and
Meg are with us hey guys how are you
good
welcome welcome good to have you guys so
where are you from Orlando Florida all
right and here to do your debt free
scream yes now wait a minute you're from
Orlando and you got matching t-shirts
with the people from the other hour yeah
so there must be a connection yeah
they're good friends of ours we met met
them two years ago when you moved to
Orlando and connected at our church and
they've been a big encouragement to us
on our journey so very cool so you guys
just booked it together made the
nashville together been planning on this
for a year so far really excited very
cool how much debt have you paid off so
we've paid off $60,000 and 36 months way
to go and your range of household income
during that time so we started right out
of college and it was 29 and now we're
right around 70 why did it go good job
what kind of debt was the 60,000 all
student loans I got the eviction notice
yeah but the old woman in the street
liked it and live with us anymore
congratulations that's awesome so the
story is you came out of college but how
did you know that you're supposed to pay
it off in three years and get with it
like you got with it I mean you did this
yeah we actually started the program two
years before that and so we're focused
on trying to minimize as much debt going
through college and then when we were
done we just we just were very
determined and to let it go as quickly
as possible and we we definitely had our
focus on it okay very cool yeah so it's
been a lot of focus sacrifice to to just
get it out of the way so we can have the
rest of our lives
good for you oh really that's how you do
it you'll get you get an attack mode so
what was the weirdest sacrifice that
people just thought you would lost your
mind yeah I think probably we work
full-time and so for Sam to get an
overnight job on the weekends to ballet
was just was weird and there's a lot of
sacrifice with that because you know we
want to hang out with their friends
we'd have to leave early or kind of
coordinate around Sam's job so that was
probably one of the harder sacrifices
and you know just the question mark like
but don't you work full time yes you
know we do have real time jobs so Wow so
you did overnight valet yeah yeah I for
a year actually when I was in-between
jobs I picked it up full-time and then I
got the job I'm currently at and I
switched to do an overnight Friday and
Saturday night so I was going seven days
a week and then I'd hit you know Friday
night and I do overnight and then
Saturday overnight and then I go and
volunteer at church on Sunday was so
you're working like clubs and aiko stuff
no Adam it was at a resort actually oh
by Disney so oh okay yeah so it's just
people coming in to check in late
yeah I'm raising another okay yeah Wow
very cool
yeah so that's better than working some
club overnight parking parking cars for
drunks there's no fun yeah there's still
some interesting characters you know
yeah I bet the middle of the night like
that you get all kinds of wacky stuff
and so we'll find you guys
congratulations very very well done
you're heroes you did it yes how does it
feel it feels really good we just we've
had our nose to the grind for so long
you know just pushing pushing pushing
and and you know questioning ourselves
and and what are we doing and still like
knowing that like this is what we're
supposed to do because I mean there are
people on the other side of this that
we're called to reach and help and and
now we can do that you know and it's
just it just feels so relieving I mean
when I turn in my two-week notice at the
valet job I love you people but I'm so
done doing this
yeah it's awesome man so what is your
advice to a couple coming out of college
and they got $60,000 for the debt that
you of 36 months ago is listening right
now what do you tell them the key to
getting out of debt is I would
definitely say make sure your Y is big
that was a huge thing for us we had a
vision board in our bedroom and we would
look and see it all the things that we
wanted to do after we were debt-free
give me a couple of those we want to
build a school overseas we want to bless
someone with the honeymoon we just want
to give a lot of money away in different
forms and then contentment I think our
generation and I know Rachel talks about
this in her new book we're just caught
up you know keeping up with the Joneses
their Instagram and Facebook and just
not being tempted to have the the finer
things in life
for instant gratification yeah it's so
easy to want to just upgrade and just
get new things and like my clothes are
falling apart and it's just like we just
got to keep going and you know to get
what you need but not what you want and
you just keep going because you know
that like what you're doing there's
there's a wife behind it very cool
that's good so having a big wise one
thing what's the next thing yeah to get
out of debt the secret I'm getting out
of it I'd the budget was huge for us
doing that written budget every month
you know and talking through with it you
know she she had to put up with me a lot
cuz I'm a free spirit but I'm the saver
and I I can pinch pennies with the best
of them so it was it was always a
struggle to figure out that balance for
you know for how we can work together
and and and take care of each other and
still and still hit our goals and and
that was that was key so communication
you know through that constant
communication um you know but it was so
vital to our success absolutely oh very
cool you guys congratulations I'm so
proud of you very well done
$60,000 paid off so we're gonna give you
a copy of Chris Hogan's number one
best-selling book retire inspired
because that's the next chapter of your
life to build wealth and do that
outrageous giving that was your big why
and you're gonna be able to do that now
not only because you got rid of Sallie
Mae but because you've learned
handle money and work together this is
huge very very well done
alright salmon mag Orlando Florida
$60,000 paid off in 36 months making 29
now up to 70 counted down let's hear a
debt free scream 3 2 1
way to go you two
you rock it that was well done yes this
is how it works right here folks man 11
11 11 hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common